on jérôme marty il est médecin et
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre et jérôme marty merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors le conseil constitutionnel on le
disait à censurer partiellement
certaines mesures de la loi prorogeant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire notamment une
mesure liée au secret médical avec le
traçage des contacts des personnes
malades
une bonne chose cette décision du
conseil constitutionnel selon vous no
est une bonne chose c'est attendu vous
savez qu'on avait demandé l'avis du
conseil de l'ordre du comité national
d'éthique de l'académie de médecine du
conseil constitionnel et de la cnil
on a vu que le conseil de l'ordre s'est
élevé contre le fait que le secret
médical soit pas fou et contre le fait
qu' on ne demandait pas un consentement
aux patients d'un certain temps il en a
été de même de l'académie de médecine et
le conseil de rona demandé à ce que les
fichiers soient surveillés au temps le
temps par le comité national d'éthique
ce qui nous va très bien et puis là
maintenant la cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui viennent en point
qui rappelle qu' on ne peut pas bafouer
le secret médical et que seulement les
personnes qui sont un lien direct avec
la santé c'est à dire des soignants
peuvent explorer et est en quelque sorte
allez allez explorer oui allez allez
utiliser des données qui sont des
données patients des volets de santé des
patients et non pas des personnes qui
sont des administratifs ou des membres
d'associations ou autre il faut qu'on
empêche le on ouvre le champ à toutes
les possibilités
parce qu'il ya un véritable risque vous
savez que le consentement du patient
autant que le secret médical sont les
bases mêmes de nos exercices et faune de
la confiance des patients et leurs
médecins
donc même au nom du droit commun il est
inacceptable pour les médecins de sortir
du secret médical
mais évidemment on peut on peut tout à
fait encadrer les choses on peut éviter
que l'on bafoue le secret médical et on
ne comprend pas pourquoi dans l'article
6 de cette loi il était écrit que le cas
échéant on trouve une boîte demandés
sont présentement au patient enfin c'est
une violence extrême
il faut tout le temps demander le
consentement aux patients si l'on
commence par ne plus demander le
consentement aux patients pour exploiter
ses propres données
à ce moment là il n'y a plus de médecine
autre chose mais on est dans une espèce
de médecine qui est une médecine
d'obéissance
or le médecin n'a pas vocation à ouvrir
alors autres censures 1 c'est celle
concernant l' isolement des malades
les sages ont considéré comme étant
privative de liberté les mesures
impliquant un isolement complet avec une
interdiction de toutes sortes y est ce
que vous partagez cette analyse moi je
partage le fait que l'on considère les
gens comme des gens matures et qu'on
puisse leur expliquer l'importance des
choses est que en conscience il l'est
face alors évidemment il faut surveiller
évidemment il faut expliquer et
réexpliquer mais en fait on ne peut pas
imaginer que l'on mette des forces de
l'ordre devant les chambres des patients
ceux ci sont confinés il faut bien que
les gens le comprennent
on va avoir potentiellement des milliers
de jambes puisque je vous rappelle que
le premier ministre dans son allocution
a parlé de 1000 à 3000 cas par jour ce
qui fait jusqu'à 525 me le test affaires
bas par semaine donc on voit bien que ce
sont des milliers de personnes dont on
parle qui pourrait être confiné et qui
pourrait se voir obliger à cet assaut
confinement donc il faut que ce soit
dans la compréhension et non à
l'obligation si l'on ne répare pas alors
du coup d'un point de vue sanitaire
quelle attitude préconisez-vous quand
une personne est malade
dans le contexte de déconfinement que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
déjà ce qu'on préconise c'est qu'on
utilise les masques dans toutes
circonstances que l'on porte un masque
on le sait dans les circonstances où la
distanciation physique rompu et puis
chaque fois qu'on se trouve en lieu clos
vous connaissez des open space pour
connaissez les grands bureaux vous
connaissez tous ces vieux ou le travail
il faut impérativement que l'on porte
des masques dans ces lieux clos parce
que la distanciation à ce moment-là
physique ne sert strictement à rien il
faut aérer ouvrir les fenêtres et porter
le masque ce que l'on nomme comme pas
c'est que on retail fermé par exemple
les parcs publics ne pas ne pas donner
quitus à se demander madame hidalgo
maire de paris mais quand la place on ne
donne pas des masses tout le monde
ce n'est pas seulement le métro
aujourd'hui il faut porter des masques
porter les masques porter les masques
dans la mesure où l'on sait qu'il y a
beaucoup de formations
pratique de cette affection est donc la
possibilité de transmettre le virus sans
même le savoir
pour conclure sur ces enjeux soulevés
par l'état d'urgence sanitaire et la
pandémie de kobe 19
est-ce qu'ils sont perçus ces enjeux de
la même façon chez les médecins
hospitaliers et chez les médecins de
ville
oui je pense que oui écoutez il ya qu
une seule médecine
ce qu'on sait c'est que la médecine de
ville va voir va être en contact avec
globalement 90 95 % des patients que la
médecine hospitalière voit les cas les
plus graves mais que le départ en
quelque sorte de l'épidémie se fait à
partir du cabinet de médecin je veux
dire par là que c'est le médecin
généraliste est le premier but le
diagnostic et qui le premier va suivre
les patients dont l'observation mais là
c'est le focus doit se faire
véritablement sur la médecine de lille
l'aide doit se faire sur la médecine de
ville les moyens de protection doivent
aller vers la médecine de ville on n'a
pas assez parlé
on n'a pas donné de masques ffp2 aux
médecins de ville et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec 38 médecins libéraux
décédé qu'est ce qu'on veut on n'en veut
plus
on continue à ne pas dire à nous dire
qu'on n'aura pas accès aux moyens de
protection masques ffp2 je crois qu'il
n'y a qu'une médecine
nous on est au service des patients mais
encore faudrait-il qu'on écoute
davantage les médecins
merci beaucoup jérôme marty d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin et président du
syndicat de médecins us l union
française pour une médecine libre